well i hope you can hear me over this
wind because the wind doesn't stop here
on the prairies
and uh here i am standing in the middle
of an iconic
prairie field a wheat field
except this isn't a wheat field and i
wouldn't have known that last week
this is a barley field
and you can tell because barley flops
over and has this
these strands called a beard whereas
wheat stands straight up
and i couldn't tell the difference until
i got here and
got a little bit of a reminder of how to
recognize okay that's a barley field
this is a wheat field
they are not identical so prairie
agriculture is
a completely different type of
agriculture than the gardens that i left
behind
in bc we don't have fields
like this in bc we don't have field
crops
this is just a complete field there's no
rows
and it's acres and acres of the same
thing seeded we didn't see that in bc
in bc it's vegetables and they're grown
in rows
and it's irrigated that's not the way
that things work here on the prairies
what's good on the prairies they have
lots of land it's cold
it's not very wet none of these things
are good for vegetables
so what they grow in the prairies is
fields like this
grasses that produce seeds or legumes
these are some of the most
energy and protein-rich plants you can
grow
and they're not the kind of thing that
you grow in a garden they're field crops
i think the biggest difference that i've
noticed so far between
this kind of farming and the kind of
farming that i left behind nbc
is just how important machines are on
this farm
you know i remember making a comment
back in
i don't know may about how
so little of what we did at amara farm
was mechanized
we were doing so much we were healing
potatoes by hand we were weeding by hand
we were doing almost all of it by hand
here it's almost the complete opposite
here almost nothing is done by hand it's
all about machines
and so i've discovered that nathan who's
the farmer here for him
being a mechanic is not just a useful
skill it's an essential skill you cannot
be a farmer without knowing about
machines
and in fact that might be his major
skill set is that he's a mechanic he
takes care of all these machines that he
uses to farm
and that's a really different approach
he's not spending all of his time
on his knees planting things weeding
things harvesting things
all of those things here are done with
machines so i wanted to give you a tour
of some of the machinery that
nathan keeps around on the farm because
he's literally got a different machine
for every single possible task he's got
on the farm
so this is a swather and its role is to
cut the crop off the ground and pile it
into neat little rows where it can be
dried
and picked up by the combine the combine
combine harvester picks the crop off off
the ground
threshes it separates it spits out grain
at one end and all the chaff and the
straw at the other
this is a dump truck yes a dump truck is
an agricultural tool because
on a field of this size it's the only
way you're getting the crop off the
field
and then how do you get it out of the
dump truck well this is an aqua
the dump truck dumps the grain into the
auger the auger transports it up and
pours it into those storage bins which
are i don't know 25 feet high we just
didn't have things like this in bc we
were carrying crops off the
field in rubbermaid bins that doesn't
happen here
anyway trying to film all these machines
presents some pretty
serious challenges to try and film them
and i'm scrambling to keep up cause i'm
on foot and they're
driving around in these big machines so
this is
what's left of my microphone for me
after i dropped in the field
and it went through the combine
harvester and uh honestly i'm kind of
surprised that i
found a piece this large i just figured
it would have been turned into little
pea-sized dust but i guess it got
treated as chaff
anyway those are my adventures this week
it's a very different experience from
the garden
i've only scratched the surface here you
can subscribe to the youtube channel to
keep watching every week
if you want to know more about what i'm
filming that's a documentary called the
hands that feed us and you can subscribe
to that at the hands that fetus.ca
or you can follow me on facebook and
instagram and i'll see you next week